हेलो गैस वेलकम तू अवर युटुब चैनल
डिक्शनरी मेरा नाम है आयुष पाठक और सेवन
लेक्चर सुनने ऑलरेडी नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
के कंप्लीट कर लिए थे आज है डेट तो आज हम
लोग और चीज देखेंगे उसके बड़े में नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड तो आप लोग ऑलरेडी
बताइए की यहां पर
जो भी टास्क थे उम्मीद करता हूं और
सिलेक्टेड देख लिया होगा वरना 8 सेक्टर
समझ में आएगा नहीं ठीक है तो यहां पर
प्लीज आप पाएंगे चैनल पर हमारे तो आपको
मिल जाएगी यहां पर नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की
टोटल सेवन एक्चुअली कंप्लीट कर लीजिएगा
उसके बाद ये वीडियो देखिएगा कोई फायदा
नहीं होने वाला ठीक है और यहां पे लखनी
आपको मिल जाएगा हमारे लिविंग पेज इस पे
जाके आप यहां पर पोस्टमा देख सकते हैं
यहां पर पोस्ट ए जाएगी ठीक है उसे पर
कमेंट कर दीजिएगा जो भी आपको सीखने आपको
मिली है जो भी आपके ठीक है तो कंटिन्यू
करते हैं आज के लिए लास्ट क्लास में ए
जाता हूं यहां पर
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी वाले
डिस्कवरी मतलब हमारे नेटवर्क में कितने
होस्ट कनेक्ट है हमने अलग-अलग तरीके से
उनको स्कैन करने की कोशिश की थी इआरपी का
इस्तेमाल किया था आईसीएमपी का इस्तेमाल
किया था टीसीपी यूडीपी का स्कैन किया था
ठीक है इस तरीके से कैसे टेक्निक का
इस्तेमाल करके हमने समझा था की किस तरीके
से अपने नेटवर्क में जो भी पोस्ट है
अवेलेबल ठीक है उनको कैसे स्कैन करते हैं
ये भी समझा की कुछ तरीके से 25 ना कर पे
ठीक है और कुछ हो सकता है की करीना पाएं
तो उनसे फिर अलग तरीके हमें जो है समझना
होते हैं अब हमने किया था पर फर्क नहीं
पड़ता ठीक है कॉन्सेप्ट से ही रहेगा आरपी
अर्जेंटीना काम करेगा चाहे आप इसके अंदर
टूल्स करें या पीस के या किसी करें ठीक है
तो वही बात है कॉन्सेप्ट से रहेगा आपको
कॉन्सेप्ट समझना है जैसे यहां पे जितने
रूम है यहां पर बेसिक कोर्स करने वाले
एडवांस
पे ही है ठीक है मतलब यहां पर उसे करने
वाले हैं
ठीक है ये कॉन्सेप्ट वही रहेगा
तो उसकी दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है यहां पर
मैंने ऑलरेडी
कर लिया है
स्टार्ट
सबसे पहले यहां पर ए रहा है टीसीपी पोर्ट
ठीक है
ऑलरेडी की आईपी एड्रेस क्या होता है पोर्ट
का तो एक बार में मैंने आपको सब कुछ अच्छे
से बता दिया ऑलरेडी की आईपी क्या होता है
एयरपोर्ट क्या होता है कैसे कम करता है
जीडीपी के लिए ठीक है पट 43 होता है
एसपीएस के लिए ये सब बातें आपको क्वालिटी
पता है ठीक है तो वही चीज लिखी हुई है अब
यहां पर आई है कुछ एन मैप से रिलेटेड ठीक
है पहले बात की पोर्ट कितने स्टेट में हो
सकते हैं तो ओपन पोर्ट होगा एक क्लोज
पोर्ट होगा अब इस बात का किसी भी सिस्टम
पे आपको क्या कर रहा है देखिए
चालू है इसका मतलब ये है ना की उसे पे
मोस्ट प्रोबेबिलिटी एक वेब सर्वर रन हो
रहा होगा ठीक है एक एप्लीकेशन मतलब वहां
पे रन हो रहा होगा और वो जो सरोवर है वो
लिसन कर रहा है ठीक है वो किसी भी क्लाइंट
कोई कनेक्ट करने के लिए लिसन कर रहा है
खाने का मतलब उसे स्पोर्ट जो है सर्विस
प्रोवाइड कर रहा है कोई उससे कैरेक्टर है
ठीक है तो वो ओपन सर्विस हो गया क्लोज
मतलब हो गया कनेक्शन कोई सर्विस नहीं है
रन नहीं हो रही है
वो फेलियर होने वाला है ठीक है अब एनएफ के
हिसाब से क्या-क्या स्टेटस होते हैं क्या
मतलब ये तो वो जो पॉसिबल है ठीक है तो ओपन
क्लोज होगा ठीक है
ना होती है वही वाला चीज है यहां पे भी
लेकिन एनएफ में क्या-क्या आपको इंडिकेट
होता है उसके आप क्या मतलब होता है ठीक है
फिल्टर हो गया अब फिल्टर मतलब क्या है
जैसे आपने लिखा हुआ है एनएफ कैन नोट
डिटरमिन आईएफ डी ओपन ऑफ क्लोज्ड ठीक है
ऐसा तब होता है जब हमने पता ना कर पे चाहे
आपको कोई प्रॉब्लम हो रही हो ब्लॉक ठीक है
ऐसे बहुत साड़ी चीज हो सकते हैं एन पता
नहीं कर का रहा है ओपन या क्लोज दे तो
इसमें फिल्टर किया जाता है ठीक है ऐसे में
आप दूसरे मेथड ट्री कर सकते हैं दूसरे जो
हम लोग आगे पढ़ेंगे अभी ठीक है अनफिल्टेड
इसका भी घुमा फिराक है मतलब वही है ठीक है
तो अंतर ये है की यहां पर पोर्ट जो है
एसएससी पाया है लेकिन समझ नहीं का रहा है
ओपन क्लोज है और यहां पे एक्सेसिबल ही
नहीं है ये डिफरेंस है ठीक है तो ये दोनों
कुछ खास मतलब नहीं है क्या मतलब की हमें
तो मैंने ऊपर नहीं चाहिए ओपन से मतलब है
पर हमें अलग-अलग ट्राई करनी पड़ती है कोई
फोटो हमारे यहां से छठ मिल जाए ठीक है
आप लिखा होगा फिल्टर है ठीक है इसका पाइप
भी कहते हैं सिंगल को ओपन और फिल्टर का
मतलब या तो ओपन है तो फिल्टर है एन में
डिटेक्टर नहीं कर का रहा है ठीक है दूसरा
क्लोज या फिर क्लोज या फिल्टर नहीं कर का
रहा है वही बात है ठीक है अब फिल्टर्ड में
मोस्ट प्रोबेबिलिटी का होना पॉसिबल हो
सकता है ठीक है ये काफी अनुमान लगा सकते
हैं तो हो सकता है यहां पर लगाओ
मेरे ख्याल से यहां पर होती है
चलिए सही
रिपोर्ट
पता होना चाहिए की कौन से सर्विस के होते
हैं ठीक है हो में पोर्ट स्टेटस और कंसीडर
म में कितने फुट होते हैं तो बेसिकली यहां
पर छे दिए हुए हैं पर होते तो कर ही हैं
एक तरीके से दोस्तों कांबिनेशन में है
चलिए यहां पर चेक कर लेते हैं ठीक है में
तो वही है ना मतलब ओपन क्लोज फिल्टर
अनफिल्टेड ठीक है इसके बाद ये कांबिनेशन
है उन चीजों का
विच पोर्ट स्टेटस
कौन सा मतलब देखिए इसका आंसर क्वेश्चन है
ऐसा नहीं की मैंने ये रूम पैलेस कर रखा है
और ये बताइए ठीक है आपको सबसे इंटरेस्ट
कौन सपोर्ट में होगा ओपन पोर्ट में होगा
वही आंसर होना चाहिए इसका
ओल्ड लेक्चरर्स में आपने देखा होगा आपको
कॉल करता हूं एक बार आप सीन करते हैं ठीक
है वहां से सीन एक आता है
टेक्नोलॉजी में आता है वहां से एक सीन भी
आता है फिर आप उसका एड्रेस भेजते हैं तो
सिर्फ और चेक आपको जो है कंप्लीट राहत है
वो कुछ इस तरीके का दिखता है आपने सीन
भेजो ठीक है उधर से चीन एक आया फिर यहां
से अपने एक बजा ठीक है इस तरीके से क्या
हो गया आपका थ्री वे और शॉप आपने
कंप्लीट हो गया इसके बाद क्या होता है
डाटा ट्रांसफर
ठीक है ट्रांसफर
क्या होता है आपका
कम जो है खत्म हो गया चलिए
का जो है आपका एक ओवर ले दिया हुआ है ठीक
है और दिया हुआ है यहां पर यहां पर सोर्स
कोड डेस्टिनेशन फोटो बहुत साड़ी चीज होती
है इनमें से की यहां पर रेड में क्या हुआ
यहां पर सारे फ्लैग है ठीक है अब इनका
मतलब क्या है इनका मतलब क्या है ये की
सारे फ्लैग हैं स्टेटिक में ये मतलब ये है
की कोई फ्लेक्स सेट करने का मतलब ये होता
है की उसके आगे वन हो ठीक है ना तो जो
वैल्यू है वो जीरो ना हो जीरो मतलब जल और
मतलब तू वही सीन है यहां पे भी ठीक है
जैसे यहां पे स्ट्रेस के बड़े में आपको
दिया हुआ है अर्जेंट क्यूआरजी फ्लैग ऐसे
कई सारे देखिए उग फ्लड है उग का मतलब की
इसको जल्दी करना है ठीक है मतलब बाकी जो
पैकेट हैं उनके मुकाबला पहले इसको प्रोसेस
करो ठीक है ये एक अर्जेंट करो ताकि
ये किसी भी एनसी वाला सीन है इसका मतलब है
की किसी भी जो पैकेट जो मतलब जो पैकेट
भेजो गया था उसका हसबैंड देता है ठीक है
ये किसी के डिफरेंस में आता है अगला पुश
ये सारे पैकेट करने के लिए होता है ठीक है
आर एस टी टी सेट मतलब आपको रिसेट करना है
मुझे गलती से कोई कनेक्शन गलती से नीचे हो
गया है अगले कनेक्शन हो गया है ठीक है
इसको आप देखेंगे कई जगह का मतलब जो
रिस्पांस मिलेगा आपको डायरेक्ट कर पाएंगे
आपको इस तरीके से होते हैं ठीक है ये सब
पे आप लोग होंगे इनमें से जो भी वैल्यू
सेट करनी है उसकी वैल्यू वन सेट होगी
जो वैल्यू है ठीक है
विच फ्लैग नीड्स तू बी सेट वेंटिलेटर किसी
कनेक्शन
हो गया अब हम लोग आते हैं एक्चुअली मेथड
पे स्कैन के मेथड पे मतलब हम कैसे फूड्स
के नहीं करते तो हो गई अब नेटवर्क में आए
आप ने ट्रेक्शन है आपने पूरे कर लिया
कितने होस्ट है आप एक-एक होस्ट में क्या
करेंगे फोर्स का रनिंग करेंगे ठीक है चलिए
यहां पर एक शायद कोई लाइव है
चलिए यहां पर पहले कॉन्सेप्ट
दिए हुए हैं तो पहले यहां पर क्या है
टीसीपी करेक्ट स्कैन ठीक है अब किसी भी
कुछ नहीं करता सिंपल बेड से कंप्लीट करता
है खाने का मतलब क्या है पूरा डिटेल लिखी
हुई है तो मतलब ये आपका सिस्टम है लेफ्ट
में ठीक है राइट लेफ्ट सर्वोच्च जिसका
आपको जो है ये टायर की जो दी गई है ठीक है
आपने सीन पैकेट भेजो है
आपने कनेक्शन इस एस्टेब्लिश हो गया अब ये
क्या हो गया
ओपन है ठीक है अब वही पे अगर आप सीन भेजते
थे ठीक है
मतलब अपने यहां पर हैंडसेट कर यार ठीक है
कनेक्शन बन गया
और करना
भेजेंगे अगर ये सब कंप्लीट हो पाएगा इसका
मतलब किसी भी क्या है ओपन है
और क्लोज कैसे पता चलेगा
अगर आप सीन भेजते हैं ठीक वहां पर स्नेक
नहीं आता है
अगर एक्ट की जगह वहां पर रिसेट ए जाता है
डायरेक्टली ठीक है मतलब सन एक नहीं आता है
नीचे तक आता है ठीक है यानी एडवरटाइजमेंट
तो ठीक है लेकिन नीचे आएगा साथ में मतलब
साथ में सिंबोस करने के लिए नहीं बोलेगा
अगर इसी तरह पोर्ट क्या है क्लोज है ठीक
है चलिए यहां पर एक कम डायग्राम भी शायद
हो गया यहां पे डायग्राम नहीं है कोई बात
नहीं समझ लीजिए मेरे जो बता रहा हूं ये
चीज अगर ऐसा हो पाएगा 3 और चिप कनेक्शन बन
पाया ठीक है इसका मतलब फोटो ओपन था और
आपके सीन भेजती वहां सामने से रिसेट और एक
आता है इसका मतलब आपका कोड क्या था क्लोज
था ठीक है या फिर एक करता है यहां पे एक
देखने के बाद ये है एन बाय डिफॉल्ट यही
स्कैन करता है अगर आप यूजर अकाउंट जो आपका
है वो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर या फिर रूट अकाउंट
नहीं है ठीक है मतलब
देखते हैं इसको अगर आपका जो है वो
रूट अकाउंट नहीं है हां देखिए यहां पर
लिखा हुआ है आईटी इस इंपॉर्टेंट तू नो डेट
आईएफ यू आर नोट एन प्रिविलेज यूजर आते बी
कनेक्टर ओनली पॉसिबल ऑप्शन ठीक है क्योंकि
यही एक नॉर्मल तरीके का इस्तेमाल करता है
खाने का मतलब कोई कनेक्शन करते हैं तो सन
स्नेक एक्स ही होता है ना
इसके लिए क्या जरूर है
जैसे आपको सिर्फ भेजना है जो आगे पढ़ेंगे
अभी ऐसा कोई मतलब अजीब सा ऑपरेशन कर रहा
है तो
चलिए आगे बढ़ते हैं यहां पर
ट्राई करेंगे
ठीक है
ये देखिए ये आपका क्या होगा किसी भी
करैक्टर स्केच
इतने
आगे बढ़ते हैं यहां पर कुछ मेरे ख्याल से
और कुछ दिया हुआ है दास f2 इनेबल फास्ट
फूड इनेबल करने के लिए ठीक है जैसे आपको
मतलब एयरपोर्ट नहीं करनी है उनके लिए ठीक
है और यहां पर ऑप्शन है आपका मेरे ख्याल
सीक्वेंशियल ऑर्डर कर रही है
तो ब्रांड नाम करेगा ठीक है ये ऑप्शन हो
सकता है
आपको कॉन्सेप्ट से ही रहेगा
[संगीत]
ओके ओके
देखिए
डिनर करने का कॉन्सेप्ट
अगर आपका रूट अकाउंट है तो बाय डिफॉल्ट
उसे डेट ठीक है उसमें क्या है उसको पढ़
लेते हैं
यहां पर मैं कैसे अलग मशीन
स्टार्ट करते हैं इसको चलिए यहां पर
स्टेडियम कैसे करते हैं हमने सीन भेजो ठीक
है सीन है क्या सृष्टि दे दिया ठीक है
डिफरेंस समझिए क्या किया हमने यहां पर
हमारे कनेक्शन को पूरा नहीं किया खाने का
मतलब क्या कर रहे थे हम सीन भी रहते हैं
ठीक है अगर ओपन तो साइन कर था और हम वहां
पर भेज रहे थे ये हमने कनेक्शन इनीशिएट कर
दिया इसके बाद खत्म कर रहे थे मैं कनेक्शन
हो गया ठीक यहां पे हमने क्या किया
क्वेश्चन बने जा रहा था की तेरे भाई गलती
से बन गया ठीक है अब ये चीज बहुत ज्यादा
लोग नहीं होगी खाने का मतलब उसमें हमने
प्रकाशित कर दिया तो अगर कोई ऐसा फायर हुआ
है लॉगिन सिस्टम है जो इनीशिएटिड की लिस्ट
रख रहा है तो उसमें ये काउंटर नहीं होगा
कंप्लीट नहीं किया क्योंकि यहां पर
कनेक्शन कंप्लीट नहीं हुआ है उससे पहले
रॉक दिया ठीक है
वही होगा भाई हम सीन भेजेंगे
लेकिन
भेजना के लिए ही हमें रूट की जरूर है
डिफरेंस देखने के लिए आप मतलब यहां पर
स्कैन करके देख सकते हैं
आप इसको वेरीफाई अगर उसे नहीं हो रहा है
तो उसको उसे करने के लिए ठीक है या फिर
अंडरस्टैंड
वही चीज है टोटल
यहां पर रिजल्ट दिया हुआ है यहां पर
क्वेश्चन है
भाई से क्वेश्चन है बस आईपीएल हो गई है
हमें यहां पर दास फिर से स्कैन करना है
ठीक है ये करते हैं टेस्ट करते हैं
अब
तो आप फ्री ऑलरेडी एचडी
[संगीत]
मैप्स ठीक है
मतलब वही है ठीक है ना मेरे को सिस्टम में
इस्तेमाल करूंगा चलिए अब इसके बाद
ठीक है
कनेक्शन
मतलब क्या होता है आराम से|
चलिए इसमें क्या होगा आपको आपको तो क्या
होगा कुछ आपने उसकी पैकेट भेजो है ठीक है
मतलब वीडियो की पैकेट भेजो आपने ठीक है
अगर आपको रिस्पांस नहीं आया इसका मतलब
पुर्तगाली ओपन है ठीक है चूंकि जो
एयरपोर्ट ओपन होगा ताकि आप ए गया अभी आपको
रिस्पांस करके बताया नहीं क्योंकि ये
स्ट्रैटलेस प्रोटोकॉल है ठीक है इसको फर्क
नहीं पड़ता कोई बात है ना की आपको पैकेट
मिला है की नहीं मिला कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता
ठीक है लेकिन हां अगर पोर्ट नहीं होती है
ठीक है और नहीं हो पाएगा ये तो आईसीएमटी
का एक आपको पोर्ट अनरीचेबल का एरर जरूर
रहेगा की पॉटर्स नहीं हो पाया ठीक है उसका
रहेगा वो क्लोज्ड है ठीक है ये यहां पर
दिया हुआ है वीसी तू गेट और आईसीपी पे
टाइप थ्री मैंने उसे दिन आपको टाइप करने
में रखा था टाइप जीरो के बड़े में बताया
था और टाइप थ्री के बड़े में बताया था ठीक
है कोई चीज है यहां पर तो एफएम क्या होता
है अगर आपको युटुब पर मतलब ठीक है इसको
जरा जल्दी ओपन है ठीक है अगर रिस्पांस आता
है ठीक है और इसको हम क्या आता है सॉरी
डेस्टिनेशन
हम लोग जो है स्कैन करेंगे
थोड़ा ठीक है कॉपी करते हैं
या फिर दी एस सी पी सी और आरसी बयान चल
रहा है ठीक है ठीक है
वेट करते हैं ऐसी कंप्लीट होने का
देते हैं
इसको देखेंगे
हर जगह ठीक है अब यहां पर क्या दिया हुआ
है
ये ऑलरेडी दास पी लिया क्या आप यहां पर
कोमा कोमा लगाके पुरी हो जाति है की आपको
22843 पोर्ट हज स्कैन करना है ये आप दास
पी वन देश तू 1023 का मतलब एक से लेक 13
तक के सारे कर दो इसका मतलब 20 से लेकर 25
तक सारे पढ़ने कर दो ये वाले का मतलब ठीक
है इस तरीके से यहां पर दास पीएफ दे सकते
हैं मतलब सारे दो कितने
57500 25 सॉरी ठीक स्पीड टेस्ट का मतलब
होता है ठीक है दास ऐसे यहां पर मैंने
यहां पर फास्ट मोड के लिए ठीक है दास दास
करके यहां पर आप देखते हैं कितने टॉप
पोर्श स्कैन करने है यानी मोस्ट आम कर
देगा यहां पर ठीक है अगला यहां पर टाइमिंग
है कुछ भी
मैक्सिमम रेट ठीक है कितने आपको एक्सरसाइज
स्कैन करने हैं ठीक है उसके बड़े में
मिनिमम रेट ठीक है कितने मिनिमम होना
चाहिए पैरेललिज्म ठीक है ऐसा कितने कर रहे
हैं जैसे आपको पता है पिक्चर दिए हैं और
उसमें अलग से कोई कॉन्सेप्ट
यहां पर मिलेंगे उनके वर्किंग के साथ ठीक
है अब ये ओल्ड क्वेश्चन कर लेते हैं ये
आईपीएल हो गया है
डायरेक्ट
चलिए
अब मैं आपको दुष्ट टीवी करके दिखा देता
हूं ऑलरेडी साथ टाइप कर देते हैं इसको
देखिए
साइज
ठीक है
सो रही थी मैं आपको रन करके दिखाई देता
हूं ऐसे भी
सबका एक जो है शॉर्ट कमांड दिया हुआ है
स्क्रीनशॉट
यहां पर
अर्जेंट है आपको टैग हो गया ठीक है वन
वैल्यू
ऐसा भी हो सकता है ठीक है तो अभी हमने
क्या देखा आपने
पूरा कनेक्शन
किन्नर इसके अंदर क्या होता है
ना करें ऐसा पैकेट भी भेज सकते हैं इसको
आप कैसे कर सकते हैं टेस्ट सीएनसी स्टेट
ठीक है यू कैन चूज दिस कैन यूजिंग दास
एसेंस विच इससे क्या होगा कोई फ्लैग
इफेक्ट नहीं रहेगा
क्या है अगर आपने भेजो ठीक है और पोर्ट
ओपन है तो कोई रिस्पांस नहीं ए रहा है ठीक
है ये इसका भी हेवीवियर है ठीक है ना ये
इसका हेवीवियर आप पढ़ सकते हैं और अगर
यहां पर रस्त आता है गलती से हो गया होगा
इसे कर दो इसको ठीक है ऐसे में आपका
टीसीपी पोर्ट जो है वो क्लोज्ड है ठीक है
ना तो ओपन
में कोई रिस्पांस नहीं आएगा क्योंकि आपके
पास इतनी क्या है
इस वाले में क्लोज करके तो अगर इसमें
आता है ठीक है वरना फोंट जो है वो ओपन
डायग्रामेटिक कर दिया हुआ है अपने टेक्स्ट
पढ़ने के साथ नहीं है वही चीज दी हुई है
यहां पे ठीक है
नहीं भेज रहे हैं मतलब स्टार्टिंग में
फिल्म की ठीक है इसको समझ में आएगा नहीं
करना क्या है भाई अगर ओपन है तो ऐसे में
क्या होगा कुछ रिस्पांस नहीं आएगा अगेन
वही से चीज ठीक है किसकी तरफ नर्स की तरफ
टूरिस्ट बस नहीं आएगा लेकिन रिसेट और एक ए
जाएगा तब जब पोर्ट क्लोज है आपका एक सवाल
हो सकता है की जब दोनों कैसे में वही चीज
हो रही है तो ये नल स्क्रीन अलग अलग क्यों
है भाई क्या जरूर है मैं तुझे से ही कहे
की रिस्पांस नहीं ए रहा है तो रिस्पांस
में इसे क्लोज ऐसा कुछ से चीज अलग-अलग है
क्यों ये सवाल सोचिए इसका आंसर ये मैंने
अभी आपसे कहा था की इसका इस्तेमाल फायरवॉल
को डिटेक्टर करने हैं फिर उनके रूल्स को
समझना के लिए भी होता है
बीच में है की नहीं है
ठीक है ना और इसके साथ-साथ
लॉक कर रहा है उसका भी एक नया लगा सकते
हैं ठीक है
इसको यहां पर मेरे ख्याल से इसको कर सकते
हैं आप ठीक है
प्रैक्टिकल करेंगे
तीनों जगह
आपको मिल जाएगा ठीक है चलिए
स्टेटस
वाला ठीक है तू क्या करेगा उसको
दो करेगा लेकिन उसके अलावा किसी को फ्लैट
कांबिनेशन डेट इस नोट सीन ट्रेड मेक आईटी
पॉसिबल तू यू रिसीव डी फाइबर और रिच डी
सिस्टम बिहाइंड आईटी मतलब क्या मतलब वही
है की इसमें मैंने आपको कहा की कुछ ऐसे
ऐसे हैं जो जिनके मतलब बिहेवियर के वजह से
अगर फाइबर आपके रिक्वेस्ट को ब्लॉक कर रहा
हूं तो आप यहां से चेक कर सकते हैं की
जैसे मां लीजिए आपने किया है और आपको ज़िद
अलग-अलग मिला तब उससे एक एनालिसिस कर सकते
हैं की भाई इसमें कौन-कौन से जो है फ्लैट
पर डिटेक्टर करने पे वो पैकेट को रॉक दे
रहा है ठीक है चलिए हो में फ्लैट तू वन
गर्ल्स को सेट कर रहे हैं एक भी नहीं कर
रहे हैं क्योंकि मैंने इसका मतलब कौन-कौन
से फ्लेक्स सेट है अंदर एक भी नहीं कर रहा
है तो हम जीरो आंसर देंगे ठीक है
इंस्ट्रूमेंट
स्कैनर है फिनिश वाला बस तो एक ही होगा
आंसर इसका
कितने होते हैं तीन होते हैं ठीक है
है और क्या करना है रिपीट योर स्कैन लॉन्च
कर देते हैं
इसका मतलब एक ही होगा
मल्टीपल आंसर नहीं हो सकता
है
123456789 10 11 यहां पर भी 11
5 की ये देखते हैं कितना आता है थोड़ा वेट
करना होगा इसके लिए
कहा था की कभी-कभी
काम करते हैं स्कैन कंप्लीट
ओपन और क्लोज्ड ठीक है कुछ भी हो सकता है
लेकिन सर्टेन सिस्टम ऑफ डी पैकेट एकदम
पोटाश ओपन करें
मुझे क्या मतलब है ठीक है जो इस तरह के
ड्रॉप कर देंगे अगर आपका जो है पोर्ट ओपन
होगा लेकिन ये सारे सिस्टम नहीं करेंगे
ठीक है अगर ड्रॉप हो जाएगा
क्योंकि इसमें एकदम जो क्लियर कट है
पैकेट रिगार्डलेस इलेक्ट्रिसिटी ओपन ठीक
है मतलब कई बार ऐसा होता है की ओपन होने
पर भी क्या ए जाता है इसीलिए यहां पर क्या
दिया हुआ है
स्कैन वोट क ऑन मोस्ट टारगेट एनकाउंटर इन
मॉडर्न नेटवर्क ठीक है सेशन से होता है अब
यहां पर क्यों रहा है क्योंकि मैंने जरूरी
है ठीक है ऐसा भी होता है आपको बस ये
समझना है की इस तरीके से कस्टम टाइप के
स्कैन हो सकते हैं क्योंकि आगे हम देखेंगे
कस्टमर कैन बी ठीक है जिसने अपनी सबसे
फ्लेक्स कर सकते हैं ठीक है
ये कोई ऐसा
कन्वेंशनल्स नहीं है इसमें ठीक है लेकिन
बताया मैंने इसीलिए आपको
चलिए इंजन उसके हो में कितने होते हैं दो
होते हैं
एक दो तीन कर पांच छे साथ है 7 रिजल्ट आया
हमारे सामने
इसका आंसर कर देते हैं 7 फिर आगे बढ़ते
हैं
पहले
और यहां पर स्टार्ट करते हैं
क्या चाहिए
फॉलो करना है नॉन रूट यूजर भी कर लगा
लेकिन अगर आपको कुछ पता नहीं करनी है
अब सीधे डायरेक्ट ठीक है अगर यहां पे क्या
लिखा हुआ है कैसे क्या है पृथ्वीपुर
जूनियर मतलब की इसको देख कर मुझे उसके लिए
क्या मतलब है ठीक है देखिए यहां पर अगेन
वही चीज आई है लेट स्टार्ट विद कीमत आपको
यहां पर लिखा होगा
[संगीत]
क्लियर
ओपन है की नहीं है
मतलब क्या है इसका ठीक है इन चीजों से
समाज होता है
ब्लॉक हो रहा है की नहीं करेंगे मतलब क्या
है मां लीजिए इंजन क्लोज है ठीक है
लेकिन अगर मां लीजिए ब्लॉक कर रहा है
भाई यानी जो फायर वाले बीच में है
जो फ्लैग वाले सेट वाले पैकेट है उनको
ब्लॉक कर रहा है ठीक है
रिस्पांस नहीं मिला इसका मतलब क्या है
इसमें मतलब
है ठीक है
वही चीज है यहां पर पढ़ सकते हैं इसके
बड़े में कुछ दिया हुआ है आपका एकदम से
चलिए
देखिए
दोनों देखने को से ही ग रहा है
अंतर क्या है आंसर यही एग्जाम
है इसका मतलब ये जो पैकेट आया है इसके जो
इसकी जो किसी भी विंडो है ठीक है उसमें
करने की कोशिश करता है समझना के लिए
क्या चीज है ठीक है वही है ऑलमोस्ट मतलब
इसमें एक्स्ट्रा चीज है ठीक है इसका भी
अगेन वही क है एकदम ये कटनी की फोटो ओपन
रिस्पांस ब्लॉक होता है तो आप एक नए ए
सकते हैं
जो हमारे इस टाइप के फ्लेक्स को जो है वो
ब्लॉक कर रहा है ठीक है
अलग रूम में आया इसलिए आया में तो वहां पे
थे जो बेसिकली पूत कैन जो थिंपू डालते हैं
जो हम लोग मोस्टली करते हैं किसी भी
स्कैनर है ठीक है लेकिन इन टाइप करेंगे तो
आगे बढ़ता है फायरफूल पे ही कम करना
फायरफूल का पता करना हो या फिर हमें कुछ
और करनी भाई सीनरी कनेक्टर से कुछ छठ रहा
है ऐसे में हम लोग टाइप के इस तरह का
स्वागत करते हैं पर ये मोस्ट अवेलेबल मेथड
नहीं है की आप शुरू करते हैं इस टाइप के
कोई भी उसे करेंगे जो हमने इस रूम में
पड़े हैं ठीक है इस वाले ट्रैक में रूम के
स्क्रीन को डायरेक्टली पैकिंग जरूर नहीं
पड़ेगी ठीक है ना वही अप्लाई करने वाले
हैं
यहां पर आप अपना
सेट है वो स्पेस नहीं देना है आपको कोई भी
ठीक है डायरेक्टली आपको जो है लिख देना है
और आपको भेजना है पैकेट को ठीक है एनएफसी
दिया हुआ है कस्टम फ्लैग ठीक है इसको
ट्राई कर देता हूं
ठीक है ना ट्राई करते हैं
हम लोग
लेकिन फिर नहीं करने वाले हम क्या करने
वाले सिंपल फिर लिख देंगे मतलब सन फ्लेक्स
को सर्च कर देने का ठीक है और इस आईपी पे
रिक्वेस्ट कर देने का चलिए हमारे पास फोन
में कर दिया मैंने अभी स्क्रीन के साथ जो
है आपके रिक्वेस्ट करने वाला है ये सीन
दीजिएगा और रिस्पांस के हिसाब से रजिस्टर
करने की जो है कोशिश करेगा यहां पे कुछ
नहीं आया है फिलहाल के लिए तो
कोर्ट पे इस आईपी सॉरी
देखिए ये फाइनली आईटी इसे आईटी नोट दे दे
एक स्कैन और वीडियो उसके बड़े में मैंने
बताया आपको भी ये आपके मेली स्कैनिंग में
काम नहीं आते हैं तो इनका में प्रपोज दे
नहीं की आप कोई वेबसाइट
शुरू कर दिया ये आपके जो भी है रूल्स हैं
सब कुछ चेक करने की ज्यादा काम आते हैं
ठीक है ना में पेपर वही एक तरीके से कर
सकते हैं मैंने आपको क नहीं है ठीक है
इनपुट करेंगे ठीक है
हो में सेट इसमें होते हैं एक होते हैं
डेट
आफ्टर करेंगे
यहां पर कुछ क्वेश्चन
करना है
क्या है
यहां पर कितने आपके
लिए
ठीक है
जरूर नहीं है
एक दो तीन कर ठीक है यहां पर डिफरेंस क्या
है दोनों में डिफरेंस आया है ठीक है
डिफरेंस क्या है यहां पर
बिहेवियर सेट है ठीक है की क्या होने पर
क्या समझना है ठीक है मतलब आपने क्या भेजो
है
उससे हिसाब से क्या समझना है इसको यहां पे
सेट है उसके साथ ये आपको स्टेट दिखा रहा
है लेकिन यहां पे कुछ सेट नहीं है ठीक है
जैसे क्या किया जितने रिस्पांस को मिल
पाएगा मैं आपको दिखा दिए ठीक है
इसको 43 एचटीटीपीएस सर्विस तो है ही भाई
और कोई बात नहीं
यहां पर इंटरव्यू
[संगीत]
करता है ये ठीक है मोस्ट स्टैंडर्ड
रिपोर्ट के हिसाब से तो 443 का स्टैंड
रिपोर्ट क्या बन रहा था एचडी स तो
अनफिल्टेड है मतलब इसको भी नहीं है
एक्चुअली में ठीक है पट ओपन ही क्लोज है
ठीक है तो अब क्या करना है आपको सिंपल
यहां पर क्योंकि एचडी डीपी है तब इसको ओपन
करके देख लीजिए ब्रो ठीक है की ओपन नहीं
हो रहा है वो देख लेते हो अंदर के यहां से
उसने कंफर्म किया है
[संगीत]
ठीक है इसका आंसर जो है नो होने वाला है
चलिए चलिए तो अब बात कर लेते हैं मठ के
कुछ फीचर्स के बड़े में जैसे यहां पर
एस्पाउसिंग इंडिकेटर ठीक है अब देखिए ये
फीचर जो है अगेन वही चीज है की लिमिटेड
नहीं है अब तक बट हां मैंने आपके
रिस्पेक्ट में इसको पढ़ने वाले हैं ठीक है
अब देखिए यहां पर पुशिंग में दिखो और इसके
बात कर रही है हो रही है ठीक है आपको पता
है ये चीज की स्पूफिंग क्या होती है
बेसिकली आपको पता ही होगा अगर नहीं पता तो
बता देता हूं मतलब रिटर्न करना है की हम
कोई और है ठीक है किसी का पाइप प्रूफ कर
रहे हैं नेक्स्ट प्रूफ कर रहे हो इसे टाइप
में हम क्या करते हैं इसमें देखिए
डायग्राम से समझ रहे होंगे अच्छे से हम
क्या करते हैं हम जो पैकेट भेजते हैं
पैकेट के लिंक
भी काम के लिए मुझे पैकेट भेजते हैं उनमें
हमारा जो होता है वो हमारा होता है
लेकिन हम क्या करते हैं दूसरे का थोड़ा सा
भी दाल देते हैं खाने का मतलब यहां पर
नीचे एक सिस्टम है जो कोई इमोशन सिस्टम है
कोई काम नहीं कर रहा है काम कर रहा है ठीक
है हम उसका जा के पैकेट स्कैन कर रहे हैं
ठीक है भारत स्कैन कर रहे हैं उसका भी दाल
रहे हैं तो हमें क्या फायदा की हमसे उसका
भी दाल रहे हैं तो हम अपनी आईडी को छुपा
ले रहे हैं लेकिन जो रिस्पांसिबल रिस्पांस
भी तो इस को सेंड होगा ना रिस्पांस तो
हमें मिलेगा नहीं क्योंकि शोर साइट में
उसका भी दाल दिया हमने तो हमने अपनी आईडी
से छुपा ली पर रिस्पांस हमें कैसे मिलेगा
तो रिस्पांस मिलने के लिए हमें यहां पर
नेटवर्क में फिनिशिंग करनी पड़ेगी अब
इसमें क्या कॉन्सेप्ट होता है इसमें तो
आपको इंटरनेट पर ट्रैफिक कैप्चर कर रहे
हैं वो कैसे होता है आगे उसको देख लेंगे
बाद में लेकिन मैं उम्मीद कर रहा हूं सब
कुछ नहीं पता होगी हमने पता था मतलब
नेटवर्क काम जो है कैप्चर कर रहे होते हैं
तो आपको पूरा नेटवर्क का ट्रैफिक कब से
करना पड़ेगा की क्या-क्या हो रहा है ताकि
आप अच्छे से समझ सके इन चीजों को की जो भी
क्या नाम है जो भी मतलब ये जो रिप्लाई
करेगा या जो भी रिस्पांस आएगा ठीक है वो
आएगा तो ये स्पंस वाली इसको मतलब इस टाइप
को ठीक है रिस्पांस आप देख के पढ़ सकें
देखिए इसलिए आपको इस मशीन कभी जरूरी है
वरना ये पूरा स्कैन बेकार हो जाएगा ठीक है
ना
चलिए यहां पर
इस्तेमाल
के अंदर है आपको पता है की अपने नेटवर्क
के अंदर वेकेंट को भी काम होता है नेटवर्क
जान के बाद काम नहीं राहत है ठीक है ना तो
अगर आप नेटवर्क के अंदर से स्कैनिंग कर
रहे हैं तो आप स्पूफ ना कर के अपना एक
एड्रेस प्रूफ कर सकते हैं से वही
कॉन्सेप्ट इसमें भी होने वाला है ठीक है
एक एग्जांपल इसका दिया हुआ है राम भाई
यहां पर सूट्स में क्या डाला हुआ है ये
रिक्वायरमेंट रिक्वायर्ड तू एन दूसरी जगह
ठीक है इसमें सोर्स में रिटायरमेंट दाल
दिया ठीक है
इसमें तीन अलग-अलग ट्राई किया है ये मैं
कैटर्स के पास हो रही है ठीक है ना अब
देखिए वन यानी इसका इसका ए गया
ठीक है
इसका एड्रेस
करने पड़ेगी ठीक है ये समझ में ए जाएगा
आपको
यहां पर यू कैन लॉन्च रिक्वेस्ट
कर सकते हैं अलग-अलग आईपी एड्रेस भी दाल
सकते हैं मैं तो देखिए
$102 कोमा मी ठीक है अब ये तीन आईपीसी से
करेगा अलग-अलग इससे क्या होगा इससे फायदा
क्या होगा इससे पहले आपका मिक्स हो जाएगा
उसमें ठीक है जब ये तीन तीन रिक्वेस्ट है
तीन रिस्पांस आया तो समझ नहीं पाएगा बाद
में की इसमें से है कौन यहां पे तो मिनिमम
तीन ही हुआ है देर साड़ी उसे कर सकते हैं
इससे आपका जो अटैकर मशीन है वो हायड और हो
जाएगा बीच में मतलब इधर से रिपोर्ट्स
रिक्वेस्ट रहेगी अलग-अलग मतलब होस्ट से
इसका मुझे आएगा कौन सा था ठीक है ना मैंने
शायद उल्टा बोल दिया था की यहां मैंने बोल
दिया था यहां पे आई थिंक की बात हो रही है
मेरा मतलब ये था की देखिए आप एक जनरल टाइप
कर सकते हैं ठीक है क्या आपने प्रूफ किया
अब भी कर सकते हैं तो ये डायग्राम निक का
नहीं है पर हां नाक के लिए भी वो
कॉन्सेप्ट रहेगा ठीक है डायग्राम बस इसलिए
बना हुआ है की आप मल्टीपल पोस्ट के बीच
अपने आपको हाइट भी कर सकते हैं ठीक है
मतलब अपना आईपीएस कर सकते हैं अपना
नेक्स्ट कर सकते हैं और आप इस तरीके से
बहुत सारे होस्टेस
कर रहे हैं क्योंकि जो सिस्टम रेलवे वहां
पर एंटीवायरस
लॉगिन कौन था में जो स्कैन कर रहा था
इनमें से टाइटल कौन सा है ठीक है
व्हाट डू यू नीड तू एड तू डी कमांड तू डू
nवें मशीन आईएफ यू तू मेक स्क्रीन अपर
कमिंग फ्रॉम आईपैड हमने क्या लिखा है इस
आईपी से ए रही है ठीक है कॉपी कर लिया
आपने और हमें क्या करना है यहां पर अपना
स्विच देखना है स्विच क्या है हमारा
हिफिन एस ठीक है और यहां पर एड्रेस करना
पड़ेगा हो गया व्हाट डू यू नीड तू एड तू
डी कमांड
और इट्स एडिशन तू यू आईपीएल ड्रेस में
दिखानी है तो हम क्या करेंगे
चलिए तो हम लोग क्या करेंगे
रिक्वेस्ट तो समझ पाएगा इनमें से कौन सा
अटैक करेगा और उसे कर सकते हैं ठीक है अब
ये टेक्निक स्पीशीज होती है छुपाने के लिए
ठीक है तो चिंतन करिए ना लेकिन अगर कुछ
अपने के लिए होती है एंट्री छुपाने होती
है ठीक है चलिए तो आज की वीडियो हमें पेंट
करनी पड़ेगी ठीक है क्योंकि मुझे आज अपलोड
कर रही है और यहां पर कुछ मेरे जैसा है
ठीक है तो आज की वीडियो ही पेंट करते हैं
दोस्तों हमारी ये वीडियो करने वाले थे
इसलिए आज यही पर एड करते हैं नेक्स्ट
वीडियो में आपको इस तरह अपडेट रहा हूं ठीक
है छोड़ेंगे कुछ भी नहीं कंप्लीट पूरा
करेंगे ठीक है तो और तो देख थैंक यू जितने
भी टास्क करने को कंप्लीट कीजिएगा कंप्लीट
करना है अगर पेड़ अकाउंट नहीं कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है
और उसको टेलीग्राम शेर कीजिए मेरे पेज पे
ठीक है तो आज की वीडियो देखने के लिए पूरा
थैंक यू